you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is game 6
from the 2014 World Chess Championship
match between Magnus Carlsen and Vishy
Anand going into this round both players
remain level they had 2 and a half
points each and Carlsen with the white
pieces in this one he opened with e4 so
far in this match it's been in a 4 vs.
d4 battle every white game by Carlsen
he's played e4 and every white game by
Anand he's played d4 so we follow game 4
once again seeing the Sicilian defense
we follow game 4 all the way up to just
moved to this is where things are
different in game 4
we saw g3 but in this game 6 we now have
d4 entering the open Sicilian C takes D
Knight takes DX Sicilian Khan to be a
bit more exact the maroc c bind with c4
forming a grip over d5 watching also
over this potential b5 advance both pawn
breaks are watched over with this pawn
here upon is pushed up before the night
plays into c3 Knight f6 Knight c3 black
pins this is threat it's defended don't
blink before you know it before we reach
even move 10 the Queen's Irgun this King
being on castled is no issue they'll
find a perfect home on c7 and black is
in a position to maybe destroy this
Queen side structure and this threat is
still well it's back on in the position
it needs to do something about that
moving forward with e5 this does not
address the potential idea that black
has of ruining the Queen side structure
if white wants to make sure this pawn
structure stays as is stays undamaged
and this is an idea to play Bishop d2
but it allows black to play e5 stabilize
the knight on f6 he won't be kicked away
and at the same time freeze this Queens
bishop
the Queen Bishop can play to e6 this is
a nice home
v5 interferes with this idea at the risk
of having this be a serious issue a
structural defect 'if I've after e5 it's
97 94 seems pretty appealing to pile up
on the pinned piece but there's a way
out of it by playing a3 Bishop takes
black is wise not to go further and go
for a pawn grab after a4 he runs the
risk of getting trapped if he goes here
there's Bishop e3 he's still running the
risk of getting trapped f6 here it's got
to go there this is not a good idea
black is up a pawn but has some serious
issues the bishop not a great piece the
King no longer such a great home on c7
coordination on b6 maybe even a 5 bit
should be six ideas not a good choice
for black to go pawn hunting is the
short story after Knight to e4 basically
could only go as far as this going
further taking that guy out big problems
instead in the game it was Knight d7
limited with your replies on the white
side Bishop f4 f4 when I was
live-streaming this game pointing out
that ideally you'd like to have the
pawns be the ones who watch over other
pawns but we'll see a deeper idea in
mind with this Bishop f4 idea it is
after all developing it can't be that
bad developing developing and defending
black is now in a position to take the
knight and he does so wrecking the pawn
structure here on the Queen side so this
is the main imbalance in the game we are
in an endgame White has the bishop hair
white also has a deficient Queen side
pawn structure black on the other hand
is a a perfectly fine pawn structure and
will just be a handful of moves away
from having these rooks
in direct connection with one another we
see that take shape right away with
first king c7 ensuing moves will include
b6 c5 and finally getting the bishop on
this nice long
agonal white comes up now with the
following plan of h4 looking to
eventually induce some weakness on the
black side this pun is already a bit
clamp a bit cramping to the black king
side structure and this pun also looks
to do similar by being planted on h5 and
then there's even ideas of rook up and
over applying pressure against the jeep
on something that does take shape in the
game b6 h5 and I believe this is a very
important moment in the game one that
can one that will change the structure
depending on this next move the
structure is brought into question here
to allow h6 or not is a big question in
the game h6 was prevented okay
if Bishop b7 is played white can play h6
and after g6 well well first off you
have to play g6 here's otherwise White's
able to take and this rook is brought
right to life for free and that pawn is
going to fall soon thereafter it's hard
to imagine he wouldn't fall so on h6 the
short story here is that black would
have to reply g6 notice how about now
weakens the f6 square Bishop g5 at some
point can be super annoying now this
could turn out to be a very reliable
home on g5 where he watches over d8 and
then it's hard to imagine how these
black rooks would become active for as
long as the bishop is camping out on the
g5 square this was an alternative for
black still even though you would give
up the dark squares to allow this
advance as in some some ensuing moves
here after Bishop b7 if black was to
allow this h6 g5 notice how there is
after let's say castles there's this
interesting idea of playing rook g8
g5 and having the knight come back here
to f8 into even g6 or f4 this is an
interesting regrouping that black could
have maybe gone for but we didn't have
this structural shift on the Kings side
of the board with g5 by the way you
can't stop or you can't play Bishop g5
right now preventing g5 because you'd be
dropping this pawn so g5 is now going to
be coming with tempo I'm Bishop d3
there's c5 f3 to blunt this diagonal and
again there's this idea of Knight to
Knight to f8 with g5 notice how the
knight would be conveniently defending
against h7 this is something I
overlooked during the game I was
pointing out that playing something like
g5 well that'd be very weakening you
know how do you defend the pawn on h7
but having this knight retreat having
the knight jump into g6 was an
interesting idea that black could have
maybe gone with we didn't enter that
particular structure but I wanted to
devote some attention to it because it's
really going to give direction to the
rest of the game once we have this
structure in play after black plays on
this move 14 h6 there's now going to be
a lot of pressure placed on the Jeep on
and black will have to be very quick to
react to that pressure following up we
have White Castle Bishop d7 rook d3 so
the ID is revealed a rook up and over to
put pressure on g7 rook a to g8
eventually comes after C 5 G rook g3
Rick a to g8 it's important to go with
that rook by the way after rook g3 and
this rook to defend well what are you
doing after Bishop d3 thus now threatens
rook H R bishop h7 attacking the rook
and then crashing through on g7
therefore it's rook
a 2g8 kind of just crawling up into a
ball but there's still very good
coordination on the black side the
knight can also offer some support to
the Kings side of the board even
permitting this g6 advance following up
Bishop d3 making sure that the bishop
cannot arrive on e4 to try and defend
some of these Kings side squares Knight
f8 and now Bishop to e3 it's important
that black is very accurate here making
one passing move just to highlight some
stuff here if Bishop c6 notice how after
rook age for Knight f8 rook here what
are you doing to defend that pawn and
you're not doing anything you're going
to drop him g6 we're just taking a bunch
of times on this square and at the end
of it white is up upon and is looking to
pick up another black has to be very
timely is what I'm getting at Knight f8
and now on the move rook h4 black will
be able to play g5 h takes G Knight
takes G Bishop takes rook takes rook
takes pawn takes and if you're picking
up this pawn here well we're going to
now enter an opposite color Bishop
ending and a likely draw rook h4 is not
the best choice here instead Bishop e3
was decided on anticipating an eventual
g5 and after this capture and the knight
recapture at least the night from g6
will not be landing on that square with
tempo against the bishop this guy he
gets out of the way on this move 19
Bishop e3 it is g 6h takes G Knight
takes his pawn is hit how to defend rook
h5 to defend this pawn is a lot of
pressure on it but black keeps pressure
on the e5 pawn as well going in for this
capture rook takes h6 there's an
immediate they take c5 he's even looking
to capture that bishop with check his
pressure on c4 as well can't grab that
pawn so easily on h6 rook h5 instead
defend z5 and from this point on we have
a lot of mmm maneuvering both sides
still trying to come up with something
to make progress these guys look like
they're not very active and while they
aren't it's tough to improve on the
black side but really how much further
progress can white make in this position
we have a little bit of shuffling that
goes on first a bishop to c2 I'd like to
point out a tactic here if for some
reason f3 the move on f3 is played in
this rook is unprotected there are these
tactical ideas present for black where
you can take on e5 and I'm rook takes
rook there's this in-between move of
Knight takes bishop I'm not saying that
this is best in any way to take right
now but I just want to highlight that
this move Knight takes e5 is available
as soon as this rook is unprotected not
the case right here in the game we have
Bishop c2 King b7 just some slight
improvements here these last two moves
the bishop gets out of the way of these
sort of tactics the King gets to b7
stays clear of some potential pin there
might be some cases where when the
Knight takes on e5 he could end up in a
pin well that's no longer the case with
the King off of that dark Square
following up we have rook g4 this is
watching over some dark squares and
looking still for a plan here it's it's
tough to say what exactly the plan is
for the white side again there is some
shuffling going on
a5 is played looking to maybe one day
have that pawn be a potential threat if
he's getting all the way down to a3 all
the significance of keeping this pawn
around on the board it has increased
immensely as without him around he
becomes just a couple square
a from queening he could even be hunted
down one day somehow with the bishop
moving forward we have Bishop d1 rook da
Bishop c2 like I was saying a little bit
of shuffling back and forth and now
finally White is coming up with some
idea with this King D - looking to get
the king over here and make some pawn
advances on the King side of the board
maybe play King e to f3 rook g3 rook h3
maybe get this structure in other words
in f3 and g4 structure having the King
on e2 to watch over what would be a base
point on F on this f3 and g3 pawn
structure the King would like to be on
that Square after King to d2 this was a
serious blunder how serious exactly well
in this position it's certainly white
who's the side who has pressure on black
right we can see that because of the
pressure
well the defensive nature of the black
pieces and the pressure that light has
lack is in a defensive position white is
in aggressive position and trying to
hold here after King to d2 however
there's now this was a big oversight
black is in a position to now take
advantage of this unprotected rook
something I was highlighting earlier
when the rook was on g3 I was pointing
out how there would be a tactic after f3
due to a knight takes on this Square and
then capturing on d3 with check well
that check move that taking on e5 and
grabbing the bishop with check is not
there that exact line is not there but
there still is a similar tactic
available for black in this position
black could play Knight takes e5 but
didn't instead playing a for this move
King d2 took about it took about just
one minute to play and the reply a4 took
about just one minute this move however
this is an important point
move 26 certainly has everyone's
attention in this 2014 World Chess
Championship match move 26 of Game six
is a big one
King d2 this was a mistake and black did
not capitalize on it Knight takes e5 was
available this rook is unprotected and
on rook takes rook let me point out on
this move here you're dropping the rook
and so on rook takes rook we don't
immediately recapture but instead sweep
in to grab upon width check this
counter-attacking move can now be met
with another check and there's not a way
for the king to throw a counterpunch
back at the knight king e2 only now do
you grab the rook and after the smoke
clears it's black who's the side who has
extra material here and black would be
the one who's pressing for a win we
didn't have that though but what a turn
of events there one blunder and then
simply not taking advantage or not
seeing this opportunity to take on e5
very very interesting moment not only
again in this game but certainly in this
match what followed was again a for
after just about a minute
King e2 so now there's no longer that
tactic available following up we have a
three f3 rook da King e1 this is a tough
one for me to really wrap my head around
I'm thinking it's to stay clear of some
Knight check I'm not completely sure
what the main idea is behind having King
to e1 it's certainly in many lines
staying out of any harm's way by the
bishop there won't be any bishop check
in this position here there won't be any
in some lines and Knight check not
exactly sure to be honest
following up rook d7 Bishop c1 this pawn
has some pressure on it black is there
to defend initially I thought to myself
why exactly go forward with
ending this pond directly because isn't
it defended indirectly like just making
a passing move if this is captured now
isn't rook a a define move and it would
be but there's an additional idea behind
putting the rook on a 8 at this moment
right here it's not just to defend the
pawn directly but black has this idea of
now jumping into the a Foursquare trying
to eliminate this LightSquared Bishop
and then maybe enter the white position
on the white squares in some way for
example if white is going in for this
type of capture maybe there's a way for
black to enter on these light squares by
way of Bishop to a4 or well more
directly he could do stuff like this
double rooks and look at that d1 square
white has to be very careful about
giving up their light square bishop yes
you could win upon on this side of the
board but you potentially subject your
king to some problems this invasion
square on d1 is the main point in the
game we had after rook to e8 King e2
Bishop a4 Bishop a4 with check and after
Bishop to c6 this is as it turns out the
main well the last big blunder here
after well I don't know big blunder but
this is not the best continuation after
Bishop e4 and Bishop c6
better resistance surprisingly enough
it's a very awkward move it's
computer-like move but it has some great
depth to it after king e7 this this is
the best move in this position instead
of Bishop blocks as we'll soon find out
after King e7 giving up the exchange and
after Bishop takes a3 this rook gets to
enter the position rook takes h6 rook a1
threatens to pick up the pawn with check
King III Knight takes e5 hits the rook
hits this pawn here rook g7 Knight takes
e4 with Czech king f4 and after
all that after giving up the exchange
this is still may be it I should say
black has maybe some potential to hold
on here though it will still be quite
difficult this night is there at least
to secure the f7 pond the all-important
f7 pun if he is no longer around on this
seventh-ranked black king will
officially be cut off and you can
anticipate mate just around the corner
this is just barely being held together
in this variation here where black is
giving up the exchange with King to a
seven but tough tough one to see for
sure in the game it was Bishop c6 Bishop
takes Knight now black for just this
moment is not so quick to now enter on
the D file the bishop is not there in
coordination with the rook on d1 so it
is at this moment light crashes through
on g6 finally rook takes Bishop returns
to a4 rook takes c6 rook d1 black has to
try for something active because all
these pawns are now falling h6 is ready
to fall and after that v6 with check
another pawn is falling rook a one
threatening rook takes pawn with a fork
white gets out of that by improving his
King position Bishop to c2 rook to e7
check in it is at this point that Anand
resigns there's simply not a good choice
here for black this last move here
Bishop to c2 is throwing a punch at the
bishop but after rook e7 what are your
options here these are your four choices
going here well that's made in one and
two doing something else such as playing
back here rook takes h6 again how are
you dealing with rook h6 there's not a
good there's not going to be a good
defense there and the other one King a6
well it doesn't have to worry about rook
takes Bishop now and so y can simply
scoop up another pond
this pond is now in a pin if the rook
grabs the pond here well there goes yet
another pond it's just too much material
there's no counter-attack against the
white king the black king is absolutely
toast in this position but what a game
this one turned out to be again going
back to that move 26 king d2 big mistake
on the white side and black did not
capitalize on in this game and it really
turns out to cost Anand in this game in
this match protect quite possibly we'll
see how things pan out but without
question seeing these back-to-back
blunders they are very very rare anyhow
I'm not sure what more to add it was
very exciting during the livestream the
whole board in this game was made use of
the center Kings side the Queen side and
well at the end again after this rook to
e7 move the King does not have a good
choice and again at this point
Anand resigned and with that we have now
Carlsen with a lead three and a half
points to two and a half points going
into game 7
we'll see what happens at that point so
that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it take
care bye
you